hey leute und herzlich willkommen zurück
aus der sommerpause denke ich mal
denn die habe ich nicht angekündigt aber
ja ich habe ich gedacht dass ich
zwischendurch irgendwie dazu kommen
videos zu machen nur das sollte wohl
nicht sein
die worte die mir auf twitter folgen
wissen auch dass ich nicht nur auf der
faulen haut gelegen aber ich habe an
zwei filmen gearbeitet einer hat sogar
ende august im kino premiere gefeiert
an dem anderen arbeiten wir jetzt immer
noch ich habe die kooperation mit dem
wdr beendet und die lokalen videos die
ich letztens gemacht hat im sommer
liefen jetzt im fernsehen was ziemlich
cool ist dann war ich auf der gamescom
ich hab noch an anderen projekten
gearbeitet wie zb bald auf dem kanal
kommen werden oder nehmen wir gar nichts
damit zu tun haben aber die meiste zeit
gegen eigentlich will ich dafür drauf
die filme zu machen denn filme machen
das eigentlich youtube videos machen
beides kostet mich zeit und energie und
beides gleichzeitig geht einfach nicht
immer das tut mir unglaublich leid das
wird sich aber verrückt vermutlich
entführt uns auch nicht wirklich ändern
denn ich studiere film an der uni und
ich werde weiter regelmäßig filme machen
und das kann sein dass sich das in
zukunft weiter dass die beiden sachen
kollidieren aber gut jetzt kommen erst
mal wieder doktor watson videos
versprochen jetzt geht es endlich weiter
jetzt wann ist eigentlich jetzt also
klar jetzt ist jetzt jetzt bezieht sich
wieder auf die vergangenheit noch auf
die zukunft sondern auch das was
dazwischen sein muss die gegenwart und
das ist lustig denn wir menschen können
die gegenwart überhaupt nicht wahrnehmen
wenn ich zum beispiel mit dem finger
schnippen und ich frage wann genau ich
das gemacht habe
dann wirst du mindestens eine
zehntelsekunde zu spät reagieren können
das ist seine reaktionszeit die zeit
steht dein gehirn benötigt um einen reiz
die bewegung eines fingers wahrzunehmen
im gehirn zu verarbeiten und eine
korrekte reaktion an die eigenen muskeln
weiterzugeben und die liegt im
durchschnitt bei einer viertelsekunde
wenn man darauf vorbereitet
beim autofahren rechnet man sogar mit
rund einer sekunde reaktionszeit bevor
der fahrer überhaupt irgendetwas machen
kann aber nur das wahrnehmen der
realität ohne reaktion geht
interessanterweise viel schneller von
dem zeitpunkt an dem die photonen eines
bildes auf deiner netzhaut auftauchen
die dann als reize über den senior zur
großen runde weitergeleitet werden
können teilweise nur 13 million sekunden
vergehen bis das bild bewusst in deinem
kopf wahrgenommen wird
das ist zwar unglaublich schnell bis zu
20 mal schneller als das blinzeln eines
auges aber es ist eben trotzdem nicht
sofort
und dazu kommt noch das licht und vor
allem schallwellen sich erst einmal
erreichen müssen bevor du sie überhaupt
wahrnehmen kann
schalte wichtig in luft zum beispiel nur
einen meter alle drei millisekunden
wir leben also dauerhaft in der
vergangenheit
wir können jetzt gar nicht wahrnehmen
weil es schon vorbei ist wenn unser
gehirn die sinne verarbeitet hat und
trotzdem muss es ihnen geben oder diesen
einen zeitpunkt der jetzt gerade
herrscht aber vielleicht ist das ein
trugschluss
dieses foto hier scheint einen zeitpunkt
eingefroren zu haben
der ball befindet sich genau an einer
stelle im bild aber trotzdem ist es kein
zeitpunkt sondern ein zeitraum den das
bild darstellt jede kamera egal wie
fortschrittlich ist muss licht für einen
gewissen zeitraum auf ihren sensor
fallen lassen um daraus ein bild
generieren zu können
je länger die belichtungszeit ist desto
mehr licht fällt auf den sensor wird das
bild nur kurz belichtet wird es
logischerweise dunkler dafür aber auch
schärfer weil objekte sich in diesem
zeitraum weniger bewegen können aber das
wirft die frage auf kann es einen
zeitpunkt überhaupt geben
die kürzeste zeit die laut unseren
gesetzen der physik überhaupt möglich
ist ist die pflanzzeit 54 mal 10 hoch
minus 44 sekunden
das ist die zeit die licht benötigt um
die planck länge die physikalisch
kleinstmögliche strecke zurückzulegen
kleinere zeiteinheiten ergeben mit
unserem verständnis von physik ja keinen
sinn da zeit nicht mehr fließend wäre
sondern kritisiert also in diskreten
sprüngen stattfinden würde
und das wissen wir nicht erst seit plank
schon vor 2500 jahren haben sich leute
darüber gedanken gemacht zum beispiel
zenon ein griechischer philosoph der
sich fragte wieso fliegt ein pfeil seine
argumentation war wie folgt zu jedem
zeitpunkt ist ein fliegender pfeil an
einem bestimmten ort wenn der pfeil aber
nur an einem ort ist ist er in ruhe und
bewegt sich nicht weil ja keine zeit
vergeht in der er sich bewegen könnte
wenn sich der pfeil also an jeder stelle
der strecke in ruhe befindet wie kann
sich der pfeil dann trotzdem noch
bewegen
es ist ein schönes paradox form auch
wenn es sehr einfach durch die
heisenbergsche unschärferelation
auszuhebeln ist aber es veranschaulicht
warum etwas kontinuierlich ist die zeit
nicht unendlich viele zeitpunkt
aufgeteilt werden kann so etwas wie
einen zeitpunkt kann es gar nicht geben
denn ein punkt hat keine dimension und
egal wie viele punkte man aneinander
reiht man würde nie einen zeitraum damit
füllen können auf unseren gesetzen der
physik folgt auch das objekte die einen
vorgang schneller durch leben als die
krankheit zu einer singularität werden
würden
mit anderen worten zeit punkte wie jetzt
oder morgen um drei sind ganz genau
genommen eine illusion
sie existieren nicht es existieren nur
zeiträume die länger sind als 5,4 mal 10
hoch minus 44 sekunden
schreibt mir doch in den nächsten plank
zeiten mal einen kommentar und das video
und ansonsten wenn euch die
hintergrundmusik von meinen videos
gefällt mein musica nova hat eine neue
ep rausgebracht ruhe die songs die ich
sonst meinen videos benutze drin sind es
noch viele weitere songs also wenn euch
diese art von musik
dann schaut man die video beschreibung
da ist ein link dazu wird auf jeden fall
mal rein
ansonsten vielen dank an schnell gedacht
das ist ein wissens kanal der
animations- videos macht und mir bei
diesem video mit den animationen wolfen
hat auch vielen dank dafür
link dazu ihr euch unten in der video
beschreibung ansonsten sehen wir uns
nächsten donnerstag wo ich diana
ehrenwort wieder videos machen wie sie
uns bis dahin nordrhein